wände floyd vorträge in schulen erhält
dann muss einmal autogramme geben und
die lehrer schauen nicht selten ziemlich
dumm aus der wäsche
was ich da so alles zu trägt und warum
er lieber inter trainer als vorbild sein
möchte das jetzt im community video mit
lief leute komisch oder boss lloyd du
bezeichnest dich ja selber als gamer und
nerd deshalb erstens was du in der
schule ein außenseiter zweitens was wahr
ist dein erstes lieblingsgames aluh jah
nerd war ich schon immer tatsächlich ich
glaube das hat heute zwar etwas andere
bedeutung und ich war auch nie der typ
der sich zu hause im keller einschließt
und vor seinem pc rumhängt aber ich
glaube das ist auch tatsächlich ganz
wichtig dass man dass man sich nicht so
dermaßen beschränkt außenseiter
beispielsweise kann ich mit großem glück
sagen war ich nie weder in der schule
noch sonst wo aber das liegt daran dass
ich oder dass man einfach wissen muss
dass freundschaften das wahrscheinlich
wichtigste im leben überhaupt sind dass
man die hautpflege muss und wenn man
beispielsweise nur vom rechner hängt
oder sonst irgendwas dann funktioniert
das logischerweise nicht wissen wollte
was mein erstes was mein erstes game das
mein erstes liebling sie allerdings ein
erstes lieblings game war einerseits
resident evil der klassiker auf der ps
wollen aber nur weil wir das tatsächlich
irgendwie zu fünft gespielt haben ich im
alter von elf oder zwölf jahren und uns
gegenseitig in die hosen eingenässt wir
haben getan sein sind geworden weil das
war damals einfach unfassbar und mein
richtiges erstes krasses lieblingsspiel
war krüger das war so das geilste
überhaupt gehört glaube heute immer noch
in meine persönliche daten traumhaften
tag noch ungern
wenn menschen möchte wissen welche
superhelden fähigkeiten hättest du gerne
und nein röntgenblick gibt es nicht
rückblick gibt es nicht hat das mädchen
gefragt sinnlichen ich könnte mir
vorstellen den männchen oder ach so
wunderschön auf jeden fall röntgenblick
schade
hettich genommen aber ich glaube ich
würde die zeit anhalten können wer
glaube das epische was es überhaupt gibt
scheiße wir natürlich wenn man in der
zeit selber weiter altert das wäre total
uncool
aber an sich die zeit anhalten musste er
muss der absolute hammer sein
ich überlege was man leuten für streiche
spielen können beziehungsweise wo man
sich über all die möglichkeiten sind
endlos also zeit anhalten auf jeden fall
geilste über menschliche fähigkeit
überhaupt freddy play fragt wie viele
verschiedene masken kostüme hast du
eigentlich wo diese frage lass mich mal
überlegen
ich hab maske aber ganz so batman habe
ich hab so eine zombie maske ich hab die
joker clownsmaske ich habe der rest sind
dann tatsächlich schon so kostüme also
ich hab noch meine zwei meinem clone
trooper helm eines tom hooper helm und
hat mich unendlich viele kostüme u12 es
ist gar nicht jetzt so unendliches aber
zwölf kostüme komplette und der rest
wird halt so zusammengeschustert darf
ich vorstellen ab folgende fragen
inwieweit beeinflusst deine kreativität
also deine ganzen ideen fantasie ins
szenarien deinen alltag und dein studium
und hast du ab und zu zombie visionen in
vorlesung zombie vision hab ich nicht
ich denke mir viel mit zombies aus
dieses setting diese endzeit und
apokalypse settings oder steampunk was
aber auch immer mit zombies ganz gut
kommen
aber das beeinflusst meinen alltag
insofern das halt ziemlich viel zeit
dafür draufgeht tatsächlich gerade fürs
schreiben und was ich unheimlich viel
nachher ist mitten auf der straße mit
wenn ich mit fahrrad unterwegs bin oder
sonstwas einfach anhalten und sachen in
meinem handy tippen mir eingefallen weil
es gibt einfach so kreativität puste
technisch wahrscheinlich nichts besseres
als durch berlin zu fahren gerade jetzt
im sommer bei wunderschönem wetter gute
musik dabei zuhören beispielsweise und
dann unendlich viele ideen
leider sollte man darauf achten sich
dabei wieder über fahren zu lassen
noch auf dem board zu tippen und etwaige
passanten zu überfahren das ist werbe
uncool und man muss sich immer ganz ganz
doll peinlich ganz ganz ganz ganz
fußball höflich entschuldigen und daher
erst zum ideen aufschreiben einheiten
voll wichtig ja hallo liebe floyd main
kanal ist jonas brothers und ich hätte
da zwei klitzekleine fragen an dich
machen was kurz und knackig ja meine
erste frage ist wie würdest du deine
rolle als youtuber auf youtube
beschreiben bist du eher der entertainer
oder siehst du dich vielleicht mehr als
stimme des volkes
die meisten wollen wahrscheinlich wissen
was deine familie deine freunde dazu
sagen mich würde es als zweite frage er
viel mehr interessieren ob das
irgendeinen einfluss auf seinem
berufsleben hat gibt es zum beispiel
kollegen oder ich meine firma zu haben
dass der sozialen bereich arbeit ist
noch andere leute ob jetzt kinder
jugendliche oder irgendwelche anderen
leute ob die wind davon kriegen was du
so auf youtube treibst du was die dazu
sagen das würde mich wirklich mal sehr
interessieren stimme des volkes für mega
geil gott waren bloß nicht auf gar
keinen fall ich glaube nicht dass ich
mit meinen videos zumindest im
seltensten fall der fälle irgend eine
vorbildfunktion tatsächlich erfülle
außer wenn ich so halbwegs zum denken
anstoße entertainer du hast das gesagt
und ich glaube das trifft es eigentlich
bei mir am besten ich will leute
unterhalten ich will dass leute das
gefühl haben was ich durch youtube habe
und zwar aus dem alltag raus in eine
ganz andere welt rein
und unterhalten werden einfach mal
abschalten und sich freuen
darüber über das halt was man sieht und
so weiter und so fort
und deswegen glaube ich trifft
entertainer hast du das quasi perfekt
betitelt was ich sagen muss zu einer
zweiten frage wo es darum geht inwiefern
das mein berufsleben wahlweise
unbezahlte praktika sieht so aus dass
ich ja wie gesagt viel mit sieben und
acht klassen an den berliner schulen
arbeite und es ein unfassbar geiles
gefühl ist wenn klassenlehrer nach 90
minuten vortragsblock meinerseits
ankommen mit solchen fragezeichen in den
augen und sich denken die sich gerade
wirklich ein autogramm bei ihm geholt
so lange sind sie doch gerne hier aber
sie haben ja schon ganz gut gemacht
es ist so unfassbar gau also und
außerdem sind die dann immer cool drauf
also man sagt hier das ist die
komplizierteste klasse der ganzen schule
nämlich auseinander
kannste knicken sitzen zehn zwölf leute
drin ein riesen glück hast die dich
kennen die sind total begeistert dass du
da bist die lehrer blicken überhaupt nix
mehr
ja im wedding problembezirk wie man so
schön sagt
das ist einfach nur total episch also
die lehrer damit so ein bisschen zu
beherrschen quasi weil die halt absolut
kein planer was abgeht und mit ganz ganz
ganz tollen klassen zusammen zu arbeiten
von daher beeinflusst mein berufsleben
tatsächlich sehr positiv und es gibt
natürlich noch mehr community videos bei
pixum zum beispiel das mit le crime
richtet das geheimnis ihres umzuges
werden sie es verraten dass im community
mit den dreien oder alexy wechsel alexy
vecsey im community video erzählt er was
wir auf keinen fall wasser niemals essen
würde also wenn euch das interessiert
klickt das von ihm ansonsten bis dann
plant